[Music]
samuel leeds is britain's most notorious
multi-millionaire property investor
best-selling author and founder of a
leading property education company
with hundreds of success students
carving their way to financial freedom
using his cutting-edge strategies
samuel is regarded as the ultimate
renegade property investor
in this year's eviction the stakes have
been raised big time
with the winner receiving the keys to
the kingdom by getting a life-changing
prize
of a whole week's one-to-one mentoring
in their own
financial freedom challenge more drama
more heartbreak and more action as
candidates battle it out to be the 2020
winner of
the eviction we had over 500 people
applied to be on the eviction
we've got 10 candidates that are part of
the process
let's see what happens this is crazy
you're evicted
previously on the eviction you know what
they're doing
from postcodes that's for my other way
because i'll pack up and go home
like i know i will because it doesn't
bother me you're going to present to me
and show me the lease option agreement
contract signed yes
yes it is well done that just came out
of nowhere
honestly not even one of them can close
the door you've secured
during the challenge i'm sadly gonna
have to say you're evicted
you are evicted
so good morning guys it's monday morning
and we are up in newcastle as you can
tell it is freezing
basically today i think we're going to
be doing a refurb
samuel won't tell nothing i've never
gone this far from london
since actually came to this country so
i'm just uh so i'm very excited
i got no clue what we're gonna do and
think that it might be a refurb
but you never know with samuel anything
anything could happen so let's just find
out and get it done
get in the front david you can get in
the back shotgun
challenge four the three finalists david
evans and lawton
i'm going to put the pressure on real
hard now they've got a refurbishment
challenge with a small budget
they're gonna have to go and find a
tenant from scratch this is gonna be
interesting to see how they work
together
ready for me to make my decision next
time on who's gonna do the financial
freedom challenge
with me this isn't even newcastle
thanks so much for coming down we're
[Music]
here
so far in the eviction you've
demonstrated that you know how to sell
you know how to make things happen
you've secured lease option agreements
you've sold properties to deals awesome
what i want to see this week is i want
to see your ability to really graft
and contribute in a refurb so this house
that we're standing in right now is
actually an infamous house
the bbc did a show about this house i've
done a youtube video about this house
being my worst house
and who is this my worst house is
because it's so big
and it's a bit shabby i've always had
bad
tenants in here that have trashed it and
this house has been trashed by my
tenants
and because it's so far away from my
house i've not i've
i never want to come and sort it out so
your challenge this week
is i have got a debit card which i've
pre-loaded 2 000 pounds on this card
so you're gonna have this card i'm gonna
give you the pin and you're gonna have
there's two thousand pounds on the house
and you're gonna use that two thousand
pounds
to fully refurbish this house yourself
now i've been i've been quoted uh from
four thousand pounds
to have a building team to come and do
it which is great
but i figured it'd be reasonable to
halve that as you're going to be the
labourers
not only are you going to refurbish this
house from start to finish and make it
look
fabulous but i want you to by friday at
5pm it's now monday morning
i want to have a confirmed tenant a good
tenant a vetted tenant
signed ready to move in by friday at 5
pm
my wife's going to be coming down on
friday she's going to be inspecting the
place
she's an interior designer she's a
quantity surveyor she's expecting it to
look good
and i want to see that ast contract
signed by 5 pm on friday with a tenant
ready to move in
is that reasonable yeah i was good all
right
good luck i'll see you on friday five oh
and by the way as well i told you guys
that i'd be providing accommodation for
the week
this is it so you'll be sleeping in this
house full immersion
so samuel has given the lads two
thousand pounds to renovate the property
which they'll be sleeping in for the
next five days
the boys will have to use all of their
changing rooms knowledge to not only get
the place looking [ __ ] and span
but to have a confirmed tenant in place
before samuels misses comes to check it
out
on friday am i gonna try it
am i gonna be the fat one that breaks i
don't trust us
david where are you what are you doing
in the roof
you see the roof is in the roof okay it
can be turned into somewhere
on the air for a week all right boys
i'll see you later i'm coming down
this is the challenge where the talkers
are gonna have to become the walkers
you cannot talk the talk when you're
doing a refurb
may the best man win i'm very excited to
see how this pans out
i've literally given them a shoestring
budget to do
a pretty big refurb so if they can pull
this off and get a tenant
a good tenant and they have a good
refurb done props to them i'll say
okay great are we changing the carpet
here what about this we're going to
leave this
circular too much to paint white well
that needs sanding down
paint again just just to seal it in just
a paint because you don't need nothing
here so
just just get cleaning products many
things
as well though
that but
well just some general trading up and
probably just a bit of often cleaner
too so
that's your job david no it's uh
oh that's sick that is
so you can get the alden cleaner evans
um
sorry so again actually if we couldn't
get nobody tonight we're screwed
because nobody can go to the toilet so
the boys head to a local hardware store
to work out how best to spend their
budget it is possible to do this refurb
for 2k
but it's going to have to be all hands
on deck getting creative on what to
spend the money on and they're all going
to basically not sleep for a week
the moral of the story here is if you
want a house refurbishing for free
set up a youtube channel with hundreds
of thousands of subscribers and frame it
as a challenge to win a competition
rather than enforcing free slave labor
from today because i tell you what it is
like i'm actually staying in the
property tonight
[Music]
your box where are you going i have
enough
[Music]
water that's because we have water in
the property now
[Music]
we have power
[Music]
oh tell me about it one thing you have
to do i know we don't get electricity in
the property
try and sort that out and find an
alternative get the generator and some
lights
they come today they don't even work
[Music]
okay i retract my previous statement
this place is a
dump and to get it to a liverpool
standard with two thousand pounds
it's going to be nothing short of a
miracle
at least the window closes
[Music]
everybody
hello
welcome to my house mikasa is sukhasana
when i see my view
that is my view we've all been given
tasks i mean
we give david a task to organise an
electrician and a plumber he just had to
ring two people
to get him to come up he boxed off the
plumber which was great
but the electrician and there's been a
problem with the box he's actually in
scottish power
but he keeps ringing the mini he keeps
saying that they're putting the phone
down or he's giving up bringing them
but he's been ringing him since
yesterday and then this morning i'm
really really happy to push him and
i don't want to speak to him in such a
way i want to
i want to lead people i want to push
people in a positive way but i really
feel like i need to give him a kick up
the bum because
he's really struggling with it he was
asking whether i should do it and i just
said look it doesn't take two people to
ring an electrician
to ring scottish power like you should
just do it that's your task just get it
boxed off that's your responsibility
he's saying that he wants to just crack
on and do the painting but there's
another two of us that are doing
painting
which i mean if you've been speaking
with people already and you need to set
up an account
just sit down with a brew and set up an
account
it's really starting to just annoy us a
bit he was talking and talking talking
and sometimes you can just talk to him
what should confuse the person on the
end of the phone and i was like david
talk less less is more
tell them there's a problem with a box
ask them that you need to make an
account
and that's it
[Music]
last night was freezing like i was
sleeping last night
it was so cold and evans came and stole
the radiator
so yeah that's hopefully this day is
going to look more optimistic we're
going to get it all painted and
i think we'll be painting all the grey
today so ideally we're looking at
tomorrow night
uh hopefully everything be painted and
new carpets be thirsty so
it's gonna be good all that dog don't
talk i was actually
getting the land of the neighbor's
stepladder last night putting my hand
over the wall
down so oh there's always something here
so
i think lawton slept last night with a
hammer
and then when evans walked in it could
have been a casualty
this morning so we could have been a man
down i've just i've hired all this
equipment as well the carpenter
has been in he's going to give us a call
and we've had a budget in mind of what
we wanted the coach to be out he thinks
it's going to be a grand he was
so sure of it and i said well let's just
keep the carpet as clean as what we can
evans comes in like a whirlwind going
going up and down and then you know
copy's a bit messy but if he says it's a
grand
it's on his head look at that dripping
you can't have that on the job that'll
get pointed out straight away
that's depressing
we can do all this work and have no
lectures here
and that's challenge failed in it
[Music]
that's perfect thank you okay speculator
all right
okay that's good that's three furions
and plumber
and electrician finally fidelity
oh jesus
[Music]
this will flow
finally
finally after two nights we get
off freezing i hope this isn't this is
gonna work
so it's been a very productive day today
um we've really really really had um you
know
tremendous improvements we woke up put a
second coat in the house
so we literally put all the rooms um a
second coat
and we got the feature walls in we
finally got our paint
traveled an hour round trip to get that
paint i we had the carpet man coming
this morning at 8 30.
um gave us a really very good quote that
fits well within our budget
we had uh the lady came in this morning
um and
already she already on the back of
that's got free viewings book for
tomorrow
we're super excited about that you know
i've been a very strict accountant and
we're still well within our means
today we have pizza that's how good
we're doing so we obviously had to win
let's do this
day three and the lads have three
viewings lined up to get some tenants in
before friday
not to sound pessimistic but it's a long
way from being the palace people dream
of living in
saying that i've not written the boys
off just yet
i'm going to default with the warrior
but the plumbing's working
electricity's working gas is working so
this just needs service if you happy i'm
happy
that's our alarm clock that's uh our
alarm clock for one o'clock two o'clock
three o'clock from enemies to best
friends
there's gonna be a row here before
friday's over because
tensions are definitely getting high at
the moment so
we'll see we'll see come friday friday's
a long way away
do you guys like this piece there yes am
i great
it was that way you're truly
[Music]
today we've had a really productive
morning actually
we've had five viewings already
um from nine this morning back to back
and then we've got
one and three o'clock and then one at
five o'clock so what we've done is we've
utilized the local estate agent and
asked them
so come and have a look at the house
give us a price of how much you think we
can rent it out for
within the market and then we also give
it the challenge to see if she could get
us viewings
for the next day and by this point the
house wasn't even painted
so we've had to work hard all day
yesterday and all through the night to
get the uh
skirts done to get all the white walls
painted so we can have a few wins and
they've come in this morning and we've
had to say to them just watch
the walls because they're still really
wet
um so yeah full on this morning like
do you know which color it is no
serious how can you pick carpet
not even known color different carpets
in the house
so evans so
he's got the budget he's got the money
and
i think he's just ordering stuff like
nobody actually
there's another thing the fireplace like
what a mess because
latin's ordering stuff nobody's telling
each other what they're ordering he's
ordered stuff now
to pick up at 12. it's after one o'clock
evans doesn't want to go get it i'm
working too
so there's gonna be a fight that knocks
crap isn't it funny it's
always the refurb challenge which gets
people arguing like an old married
couple
if that was me then that would be
like okay someone has to do team leader
but we're not
want to be chinese and say we're not
doing it that's i'm not
going to cause conflict but i know what
i'm doing i'm getting stuff done i'm
organizing it but he's happy enough
cutting next to more neighbors anyway so
i think i think overall samuel will be
happy with that
regardless pretty much done now just let
you know you should be super happy about
that
that'll make a big difference
everybody just said those would be truth
she's captured all the viewings she said
that she'll be here friday 12 p.m with a
signed
agreement with well attendance
bro banging amazing david
come here bud these are the texts from
jess
saying this has cancelled all the
viewings for the rest of the day because
she'll be back on friday with a signed
agreement
serious yeah brilliant well done hold on
freddie turning in friday said you'll be
here friday 12 p.m with a sound
agreement i think the tenant will also
meet with there too
thank you
that's the hardest bit that's brilliant
20 fingers we actually need to get it
ready
excellent news so just the estate agent
has had confirmation from a tenant and
will have a fully signed tenancy
agreement for the lads on friday well
done boys
are you going to fit in the car i'm
literally gonna open the boot
i'm gonna bring the back seats down and
i'm gonna put the front of it near
towards the windscreen and have most of
it on the back
it's only like just a five minute drive
so uh we'll be all right we'll make it
that's what we have to do man we have to
think outside the box
to me to you
stop here
thank you
[Music]
that's my budget then 20 pound for
everything free bits and the saw
so i have a 20-pound budget for the
kitchen you've got 200-pound budget for
for the bathroom yeah yeah and we still
have like 250 pounds left after
everything's done that sounds
are you confident that you can fit it
yeah of course
[Music]
oh
[Music]
seven o'clock
no cheeky little head shower you've got
to take these luxuries when you go
you know it's not been working for the
past two days so i'm going to take full
advantage
i can't have a pool shower because i've
not got a towel
that's all right i'll use david's
[Music]
this is where most of my thinking goes
it's my quiet room
so room to get away from everybody i do
just take them down when we get the
sponge in the bucket just maybe clean
them down
i mean i would like to get rid of the
ceiling this ceiling ceiling's been
dropped because i can see the original
ceiling through there
and the plaster just completely fell off
it so that's why they see they've been
putting
it's just an old cheap
tired ceiling
just costing us time
[Applause]
[Music]
look
[Music]
i'm just waiting for the carpet to come
in and get a feeling
and then it's going to be voila
amazing we didn't know that the carpet
fit i wasn't responding last night we
would be able to
arrange alternatives
what i feel like he's been trying to do
his life trying to
pull someone out the back to make
himself look really really good but he's
been backfiring communication is key on
a project especially when it's streaming
better it's better to have a fight
rather than it's better with each other
because at least we knew exactly where
we were standing
the intentions is good everyone wants to
get the best but of course it is like
out here it's
you understand it i just feel like he's
been singling himself out
to try and make him look like the hero i
think the future but it doesn't always
work
are you saying because there's no thing
yeah if you and
evans are looking for carpenters and
we'll just carry on what
right yeah right we need to be ten
minutes
and then we can just carry on right now
to network if everyone who walks inside
being cute
to find a carpet feel to fit this carpet
tonight tomorrow whatever we have to do
whatever it takes is going to happen
mask
sorry lads it's a quick one one
to help us out i can't fit her yeah
um like literally like tonight's last
tomorrow
see you misses yes on instagram
it's a good light you know i can see
i'll see if i can get a lot of messages
did he give you the chocolate
last night yes you did
[Music]
um a very very very random question yes
would you happen to know anyone who can
feed the carpet by any chance would you
fit in sorry pizza carpet a carpet peter
we literally been let down by by
somebody within the coming today and um
i'm gonna give you this number you get
one which has been fitted
mine really yeah just we just moved in
here like beginning of the month
so you fit the carpets literally within
a certain amount of time
and the guy was meant to come and see
that he came into the measurements
give us a quote and then just the answer
well mine
has been fitted by carpet right okay
okay
he's been figured by carpet right so
he's a professional carpet fitter
so he's really he's been he's a
professional fitter for corporate right
but okay cause he's doing like the
you know the odd job in the science oh
literally this uh just
would you happen to know anybody who can
fit your carpet by any chance they live
right there
okay we're in the same boat then
the main issue is that it's just so late
notice
it's it's thursday night eight o'clock
at night and we're trying to book in
a carpet fair to do a three-bedroom
large
house throughout
even this evening which i mean it's
eight o'clock at night
or tomorrow morning and people are just
booked up
basically the carpet feather let us down
tonight
what i'll give you bro where's the [ __ ]
inside me
communication is key on projects there's
a plan then
if you can give us a call first thing in
the morning just to confirm whether you
can do it tomorrow at 11
that'd be amazing if not give us a call
anyway and just let us know that you
can't do it and then we'll get you
booked in for next week and we'll put a
deposit up for you
uh-huh do you know jay the guy giving
the chocolate yesterday
he actually put out um a facebook ad
and he contacted jay and jay called me
and told him i'm gonna give this guy a
number and then he called me
and then yeah i was just like for about
half an hour pleading on the phone with
him and then
he said i'm gonna come tomorrow it's
like we need to get a copy can you come
tonight i'm gonna go come pick you up at
your house
and it's just like i'm gonna come down
come so you can't always take the
measurements and um
hopefully we'll get everything done
tomorrow started
i mean you heard what a guy said bro i'm
really hoping for a massive kickoff
don't let us down lads
i feel like you're being a bit cold i'm
not being caught bro it's not faking
that i'm just not going to bite into
you know what are you trying to get over
me bro yeah what was i saying
it was just poor communication that's
awesome that's cool bro that's fine
let's just let's just focus on what we
have to do and then after the eviction
let's talk man but right now let's just
focus on what to do
can i have a big mac and a carpet
shutter face
so it's half 11 now and we are
flat out we've got so much to do still
as you can see a lot of it is actually
just like
small touching up so like i'm painting
this flower just to like bring out the
texture of
now five days tomorrow we've done so
much in that time we've completely
transformed the house it's gone from
like an absolute bomb site
to like a really nice family home with a
nice little family moving into it
so i'm pretty proud of it to be fair
[Music]
as the final day dawns on the boys
project
there's a bloody stormer brewing he's
not going to get it
nothing you don't want to know do you
need to i've been trying
you've called me you've texted me i
haven't answered you because i'm trying
to
what i'm trying to say bro i'm not
saying that anything that you said is
not valuable it is valuable
what i'm trying to say is that we have a
task yeah
please don't turn this around you need
to be super positive
because that's what you'll always do we
do have a task yeah we need to work
collectively together yeah
as a team yeah not single you don't just
drive off and go and buy things without
confirming it with all of us yeah
because that's the reason why we are
massively over our budget yeah because
you've not been keeping track of it if
we had more conversations and we're more
transparent and we're more open about
the objectives that we're trying to
achieve yeah we would be able to achieve
them
quicker and efficiently
stay away from me until the end of the
eviction that's fine
that's right
yeah that's fine cool thank you very
much and that right there
is all of the teamwork and camaraderie
the boys have accumulated over the last
few days
shattered into a million tiny paper
shaped
pieces
what's your favorite part
was that gonna get sold yeah yeah what
do you think of this
don't be mean be honest with it
right yep
on monday it was one of the worst i've
ever seen um in all my years of being in
a stage and this was this was literally
one of the worst houses i've ever seen
it was filthy it was full of stuff
things were smashed it would have
literally been impossible to find a
tenant here this transformation
is incredible absolutely and we've found
a tenant in less than 24 hours for this
house
and it hopefully will be here forever
yeah
that's what she said that's what she
said looks so good now
and she saw it before and she loved it
because of the location because of the
size
yeah um and now she's come back today
and she's she's just buzzing
buzzing she said she's never going to
leave this house now yeah so from an
estate agent's perspective that's about
what we want to hear yeah the lads have
finished their refurb within their 2k
budget
and despite bickering like [ __ ] girls
they've actually done an amazing job
hello
new carpets throughout full painting
reconnection of main utilities
and most of all a touch of love and care
that the house has been missing for a
very long time oh wow it does look
different how are you
a good friend
wow wow wow oh
goodness oh wow
oh wow i'm um
to be honest i was thinking
the carpets needed changing because the
car was really bad yeah yeah yeah
i was thinking that i either gonna clean
them or
change them and i genuinely didn't think
they'd be able to get a carpet fitter
and get it done in time so i imagine i
imagine they've got a carving fit i
can't
i don't i'd love to hear the story we'll
hear the story from the guys afterwards
this is a new kitchen almost looks like
a new kitchen it does look like a new
kitchen
this definitely looks new it looks
really fresh
have they painted one of these what have
they actually done to this kitchen
i think it doesn't look new but it was
very different
okay i'm gonna just cleaned the crap out
of it yeah and i think the paint at the
the doors which is real
this is no need to remember before when
it was um
remember before and it was just like a
volcanic
[Music]
like an amazing kitchen but i think it's
decent and presentable
it is and they've clearly painted the
whole house on there i know
i'm careful not to touch the walls
because i imagine it's fresh
new taps there are new tabs black modern
tags
yeah they are pretty cool
toilet seat looks on you
yeah they have done wonders
i i can't i can't lie i think even just
the paint has changed a lot i think it
feels more bright and just nicer
just even with the paint i learned
i think the biggest thing i'm impressed
with is the time frame that they had
yeah like five days i know five days no
pre-planning
so they had no idea in an area they
don't know anyone
and they've literally painted every
single yeah and that's pretty good going
this was this was all moldy there was so
much mold and
bottle of cider up there that was all
the
work they weren't
[Laughter]
to see what they've actually done with
the with the damp work
yeah because there was a lot of model
they just painted over it i wouldn't
blame them if they have
or have they actually seen to it yeah um
yeah i mean you know there's still
obviously issues like this
very dirty mouldy blind but
but hey again i have two thousand had
five days
i am i am impressed it's better than i
thought
i wonder why they chose black i guess
you don't see stains it's one of the
best colors
for me i'd be like ah because then you
can see everything i have a little white
every little white bit i've never ever
go through gray but it's a nice contrast
i've never ever ever put
and they're not workman that's not their
thing you know
fantastic well guys
we've got a few questions for you folks
in terms of
tenants now obviously the challenge was
2 000 pounds you stuck to budget
which is which is amazing how much did
it come down to exactly by the way
it came down to it it came down to the
pennies
and what time did you finish like what
how long has this been have you been
waiting for hours or no no
we finished like minutes before you
arrived isn't it funny though funny
isn't it funny that you were given
an exact budget an exact time frame and
it took
almost within the second and within the
pen yeah it kind of goes to show
what you can achieve when you're yeah
when you're working through that budget
like we didn't have money for cleaning
products so we had to ask neighbors
yeah two things you had to do number one
we had to get to lift the property
restore it renovate it
we've looked around the property in full
amanda you're the interior designer and
the surveyor what i mean what are you
do well i know what it takes to do this
kind of thing cause i used to do all the
time
turn houses around so in the time that
you've had i do you think that you've
done a good job because
five days yeah like no pre-planning
new area you don't know anyone having to
like call up people
i think you've done yeah i think you've
done well i think you've done well
i think so thank you however that was
only
half of the of the challenge yeah which
you've smashed the other half was
i wanted a tenant by stop by today
how's that how's that going we're not
right i mean we actually had a tenant by
wednesday wednesday and yeah she
verbally committed and then she came
today
with the agent
wow wow she's like
she's vetted she got vetted she came to
view it again she came to view it when
we was halfway through she came to view
it at the end
on friday today and she signed at twelve
o'clock so
made up her partner came yesterday as
well yeah that's great
she gave me for the night she's actually
in tears wouldn't she yeah she yesterday
so out of the three of you then i mean
who who
who really made this happen would you
say like because it's it's a it's a lot
that's happened
so what would you guys say i think it's
uh i think all knowledge
it was a team effort i think um we
definitely came together as a team the
first video wouldn't be here we had no
hot water slipping on the floor um so
after the first few days
we kind of jailed and obviously we were
obviously all in unity so combined
collectively
we made it happen yeah you're kind of
like forced to be friends
obviously were there any were there any
um obviously
to begin with there was no heating and
then you got the heating working but
were there any heated moments between
you as a threat was there any fallout
yeah definitely
it was definitely a couple because we're
under pressure with time
budget and we all picked and chose roles
and responsibilities within the project
yeah so you know even though we all
painted it
together collectively but then we then
moved into separate parts of the house
like i took over a bathroom and i did
all the bathroom because it was
problems there were leaks and then took
over the kitchen and then you took over
the rest of the snacking with the
paintwork and the doors
and then you did the back garden didn't
you as well so even though we all
had our responsibilities we did get on
top of each other a little bit
but that's to be expected yeah yeah and
as we spoke afterwards like
sometimes it's best to just have it out
with each other straight away
yes and then i was trying to come back
and just hold your makeup and just get
on with the job
yeah so i did say to you the beginning
of the week that i wanted you to
to make mountains move and it looks like
you've had to do that
tell me david what were the key learning
points of this whole experience
time time to be going and just making
things
happen you know you can't wait for
people to come here if they're not going
to be here you just have to be on the
phone and
have backup plans that was the key it's
amazing because i think as an
entrepreneur as a property entrepreneur
you need to be able to make stuff happen
yeah i mean we had to think outside the
box i think
this really tested us and it really did
make us think outside the box you know
even down to budget
it was like you know what do we do we've
got no money for cleaning wraps and it
could knock on next door
you know we was cutting the ivory out
the front because it was completely
overgrown at the front
we didn't have any um chops to cut the
ivory so knock on next door we just
used the local community and they were
nice oh yeah
i think we can agree that this is a
challenge
accomplished this week and you've all
worked
really really hard so i'm gonna be
having to choose one person
who's gonna win the eviction and i'm
gonna be doing the financial freedom
challenge with them and that's gonna be
a completely
life-changing financially and also
personally challenge
so what i want to do now is i want to
get to know you a little bit as
individuals
and work out who the strongest candidate
is between the three of you
and the way to do that is i want to give
you some training
i want to visit you all at your own
homes i want to introduce you to some of
my business associates
go over your business plans and then
decide who the strongest candidate is at
the three of you
which we'll be doing so right now you
guys look knackered i think you need to
go home i think you need to sleep
and i want to meet you monday morning at
8am at my castle
in worcestershire so great job and we'll
see you on monday
thank you very much good job tomorrow
don't know whether he's going to be able
to take the pressure
of a financial freedom challenge i don't
know whether he's going to be
the kind of person that might melt under
that kind of pressure i don't know
do you know i was expecting you to
dominate this yeah me too
i am going to be spending a week doing
the financial freedom challenge
with